what do you miss most about playing andy
and that chapter of your life
i miss every single thing about it
every day that was the greatest chapter
of my life so far
do you ever see a revival happening
i mean the secret society of
second born royals what was it like
filming this movie
filming this movie was an incredible
experience for me it's the first move
i've ever been a part of
so it was every single experience was
completely new
but it was so much fun um i met so many
amazing people and had so many
unforgettable experiences so all around
a really great experience
behind the palace gates and in the
shadow of my sister
the soon to be queen
[Applause]
it was me the second born who was chosen
to protect
our kingdom it was really cool to see
sam
who is the first disney princess of her
kind
i'm curious what drew you to this really
unique role
i connected so closely with sam and with
her story
and with her struggles with finding out
sort of where she belongs in this world
and how she can sort of take all the
things she's been given
and this title that she was born with
and really turn it into something
meaningful
and something valuable to her and i
think
it's a very universal theme of wanting
to
create your own legacy and make that
legacy something that you feel
inspired by and empowered by i really
appreciated the fact that although
the story follows these princes and
princesses
and superheroes um the themes
run true for anyone you know you don't
have to be a superhero
or royalty to really um connect with the
story i wish i had had a sam
when i was a young girl you know to
watch and feel inspired and empowered by
and you know i think a really cool theme
about this movie is that
like you just mentioned it's all about
embracing your truest self
so i'm curious peyton what is a quality
that you initially maybe felt insecure
about or it made you feel
different that you ultimately turned
into your superpower
the qualities that i find about myself
that are um
what make me unique but are also things
that make things difficult sometimes
are qualities that sam has as well you
know this
strong-willed um personality and
being intensely independent
are both things that i really um feel
that i have
and that sam also has and both of those
qualities
are great characteristics you know it's
so incredible
that for people to you know be
independent and be proud of who they are
and do what they want when they want to
do it because they want to do it you
know and that's such a great quality
but also having such um independent
instincts and wanting to do everything
by yourself the way you want to do it it
can be very isolating
you know and and it can it can separate
you from other people you know
people get close to each other by
leaning on one another
by asking for help by learning from each
other and when you're very set in
i know what i'm doing and i'm going to
do it by myself
um you can you can miss out on those
opportunities to build relationships
and that's definitely something that
i've struggled with and sam struggles
with through the movie
um and sort of figuring out how to use
those inherent traits
and funnel them into something positive
where the fairy tale ends is where our
story
begins i have to ask you the movie of
course
ends perfectly set up for a sequel
have there been conversations and i'm
curious what you want
chapter two for sam to look like yeah i
mean i think
um it is a true testament to how solid
the story is that there are so many
places for it to go for another movie
you know the story isn't just
like that's it you know by the time the
book is over there's
a lot of opportunities and the story
really lends itself to a sequel
there haven't been any official
conversations like we don't know what's
happening yet
um but i definitely really hope it
happens i just think
sort of diving deeper into those
relationships that we establish in the
first movie
is going to be really key we meet sam's
family
we learn a little bit about them we see
her interact with them a little bit but
we don't
we don't go as deep as we could and it's
the same with her relationship with
james
her teacher and also the members of the
secret society
i was sensing a little bit of possible
romantic friction maybe with
mike maybe with tuma is that something
that you'd want to see explored
i mean definitely i mean who doesn't
love a little romance in a movie
right sam needs a little flirtatious
action exactly
and like i really love that in the first
movie there's no like boy influence
which i think is super empowering and
super important and great about it
but i definitely think if there were a
second one maybe a little love triangle
situation
could be kind of fun before i let you go
i just want to take a little stroll down
memory lane because you know your andy
mac fans are going to be watching this
movie
you're really the coolest girl i've ever
known oh i'm really enjoying all the
compliments
what do you miss most about playing andy
and that chapter of your life
i miss every single thing about it
every day that was the greatest chapter
of my life so far
i mean the people i met i miss every day
i mean
it really was super difficult for me
when that
um series ended because it was a chapter
of
a huge chapter of my life it was pretty
much my childhood is sort of
bookended by that show seasons one two
and three
andy mack the story was so important to
me
and the characters and the lessons and
the stories that we told were so
important to me and
it was more than just entertainment it
was it was actually making an
impact so coming off of that obviously i
don't want to
compare my projects you know because
everyone's different and you love it for
different reasons
but i wanted to find something that i
felt you know was equally important and
relevant in our world
and so hopefully this movie um
does that please tell me everything's
gonna be okay with the secret baby
i'm the secret baby bex is my mother and
my mother is my grandmother
do you ever see a revival happening
i mean i definitely do
and i would be super excited to do that
i'm still
really close with all the cast members
we talk all the time
and i definitely think that that's
something we would all be really excited
about and really wanting to happen
i think that story still has so much
that has not been told as far as
high school years and i just think
there's a lot of really fun opportunity
there
um and already this great built-in fan
base so
is there a cast group chat there is of
course
what goes down what goes down in that
group chat usually
just like dumb stuff like you know
people send like
weird videos every once in a while
seminal texts like i miss you guys and
we'll
just be like oh i miss you too because
that was just such a huge part in all of
our lives and part of what made that so
special was that everyone felt equally
connected to it
so yeah we're we're all definitely still
crossing our fingers and
we'll never give up hope on on that one
coming back
you're a queen i want to see you doing
two franchises andy mack and secret
society of second-born royals i think we
can do it it's 2020.
i completely agree we need some good
news at this point in our world